for a while now the resentment towards
billionaires has been on the rise
as people criticize them of having too
much and not giving
nearly enough we have people suggesting
that individuals making over 10 million
dollars per year
should be taxed at a whopping 70 while
others
believe that billionaires are slave
drivers but
when did becoming a billionaire
transition from an aspiration
to something that is looked down upon
well starting off the number one reason
billionaires receive criticism
is because their wealth is perceived as
unfair in a variety of different realms
starting with taxes not paying their
fair share of taxes
is one of the top complaints against
billionaires but
is this actually true for something to
be unfair
it should be inaccessible to the average
person in other words
it should be a privilege of the rich
however
billionaires follow the same tax codes
and rules as the average person
thus if the average person also grew
their money using stocks or real estate
or any other type of asset that provides
capital gains
they too wouldn't have to pay taxes on
this growth until they sell
but i get it billionaires have a lot
more money
so they can afford to pay a larger
portion well
here's the thing though billionaire
wealth seems like a lot from our
perspectives
it's not a lot from a national
perspective the total wealth held by
billionaires in the us
is 3.382 trillion which is no doubt
a lot of money but again not much for
the government
let's even forget about taxes even if
you took their entire wealth which adds
up to 3.382 trillion
you wouldn't be able to fund the us
government for a single year
at today's rate you would barely be able
to feed the government for over
half a year to put this in perspective
their cumulative wealth would barely be
enough to pass just the first stimulus
bill
and that's at today's spending levels
imagine if medicare was extended to
everyone
and only their incomes were taxed now
i'm not saying that billionaires are
incapable of contributing more
or that they shouldn't contribute more
rather i'm simply trying to show
that billionaires are not the bottleneck
to various welfare programs
as many politicians suggest many
politicians suggest that taxing the rich
will solve
everything from poverty and expensive
health care to climate change in north
korea
and the truth is countries that do
achieve such welfare programs
don't do it by taxing the rich alone but
rather
taxing everyone as taxing the rich alone
is not
nearly enough for instance the income
tax in denmark
is 55.8 percent the income tax in sweden
is 57.2
and the income tax in finland is 53.75
it should also be noted that all of
these countries have sales tax rates
well over 20 percent so not only do
billionaires follow the same tax rules
as everyone else
but taxing billionaires more is not the
key to humanity's biggest issues
as you may have been told it should also
be pointed out that many of the richest
billionaires
including bill gates warren buffett and
mark zuckerberg
have pledged to give 99 of their wealth
to charity
at the time of their death not to
mention many of them
have already donated tens of billions to
noble causes
next up people often look down on
billionaires
as they perceive them as making billions
off the backs of their employees
the company that is most often pointed
to as running off of slave labor
is of course amazon but here's the thing
with amazon
they literally cannot afford to pay more
people
often point towards ceo jeff bezos as
making tens of billions per year
however you have to keep in mind that
this isn't in the form of a paycheck
from amazon
99.99 of jeff bezos wealth growth
is thanks to his ownership of amazon
stock his cash salary from amazon
is a very modest 81 840
the other 1.6 million you see here was
spent on various security measures to
keep him safe
moreover he doesn't receive any
additional stock unlike other top ceos
like sunder piche from google
and tim cook from apple who receive
hundreds of millions of dollars in stock
every year as for amazon workers the
minimum wage at amazon
is already over double the minimum wage
at 15 dollars per hour
and this has been true for nearly two
years now
the problem is that even increasing this
by just another
six dollars per hour would cause amazon
to be unprofitable
so it's not like jeff bezos is making
billions by not paying his employees
amazon simply can't offer a higher
salary because their profit margins are
a very meager three percent
conversely companies that are very
profitable
do pay their employees very well the
median google employee
earns over a quarter million dollars per
year and this is the same case with
other top companies like facebook
furthermore billionaires with tens of
billions or hundreds of billions of
dollars in wealth
have created trillions in wealth for
others going back to jeff bezos
him and his ex-wife only owned 16 of
amazon
considering that amazon is worth well
over one and a half trillion dollars
this means that he has created 1.32
trillion dollars in wealth for others
or in other words us if you keep your
money in a large bank such as wells
fargo or chase bank
or if you invest in your company's 401k
plan which is managed by fidelity or
vanguard
you have profited from amazon these
institutions
love to put your money into companies
like amazon
apple and microsoft as they provide
phenomenal returns
consequently the companies of
billionaires either pay their employees
really well
or they pay as much as they possibly can
and
as for their capital gains though they
may have tens or
hundreds of billions of stocks
themselves they have created hundreds of
billions
if not trillions for the rest of us and
that brings me on to the final gripe
that people have with billionaires
which is that they think they got it
easy many people feel that a large
portion of billionaire's wealth is
handed down from their parents
and they don't think this is fair but
this is simply not true
a study of people worth over 30 million
dollars found that 67.7 percent
or two-thirds of these individuals were
completely self-made
23.7 percent of them both inherited and
created a substantial portion of their
own wealth
and only 8.5 of these individuals
inherited all of their money
this ratio becomes even stronger when
you look at the richest people in the
world
9 out of the top 10 billionaires in the
world are completely self-made
mukesh ambani is the only one who has
inherited a significant amount
but he too has grown to a point where
the majority of his wealth
is self-made aside from the majority of
billionaires having created their own
weld
it was by no means an easy journey
either it took steve jobs
32 years to release the iphone after
starting apple
amazon was sued by both walmart and
barnes noble in the late 1990s
and it took amazon until 2018 or 24
years to actually make their ecommerce
business profitable
similarly it took elon musk 18 years to
simply get people to the international
space station
and it took 10 years of tesla being a
public company for its potential to be
finally realized by wall street
evidently most billionaires don't
achieve success overnight
but that's the only part we see we only
see that jack ma
is worth 50.3 billion today we
overlooked the fact that at one point
he was rejected from a job at kfc and
that he got rejected from harvard
11 times people simply criticized that
donald trump has a rich dad
however they overlooked the fact that he
was over a billion dollars in debt at
one point
and that he has lost over half his
wealth since becoming president
i'm not saying these people worked any
harder than the average hard-working
individual
however they have taken much bigger
risks
and created exponentially more value
than the single mom working 16 hours a
day at mcdonald's
or the nice neighborhood uber driver on
top of this
most of them have failed several times
losing millions of dollars of their own
money
before finally making it and most
importantly
at the end of the day their success has
nothing to do with your success
or lack of success taxing them more is
not going to solve your problems
nor is it going to help you succeed so
let's drop the negative stigma
surrounding billionaires
and go back to aspiring to be one after
all
most of them were just like you and me
not too long ago
but that's just what i think drop a like
if you guys agree
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]